Hi. Welcome to Version Control.
I'm Carolyn, one of your instructors for the course.
>> And I'm Sarah, your other instructor.
In this course, we'll cover the concept of Version Control and
why you might want to use it.
>> Yeah. So, Version Control is sort of like having a giant undo button for
your project.
>> You mean like this one?
>> Yeah, exactly.
It makes it easy to save versions of your files at different points in time.
You can also restore previous versions and compare different version.
Yeah, it also makes it a lot easier to collaborate with other people.
>> No more sending huge .zip files of your project back and forth.
>> Now, learning to use Version Control is a little bit like learning to type:
it's hard at first, but once you can do it, it makes you a lot more efficient.
>> You might feel like learning a whole new system to keep track of versions of
your files is a lot of work and maybe not worth it, or
that if you're hard core enough, you don't need Version Control.
But if you look at successful companies like Google and
Facebook, you'll find that they all use Version Control internally.
What about you, Caroline?
>> Well, when I first started using Version Control,
I basically only used it when I needed to.
But now I like to use it for all of my projects.
It's kind of addicting.
>> Cool.
Let's find out why.